the hell is the goddess of death and  I've had incredible fun playing her oh  I've missed this tell us the first  female villain that we've had in a  Marvel film and Cait has destroyed the  idea of your typical villain kneel  before your queen loved working with  Cate Blanchett I was so excited to see  what she was gonna do it hello as this  insane off-kilter  attitude you know like a smart boy how  would you like a job  I think the best villains are always  those that you kind of love and hate  what they do but you sort of understand  it there's a logic to it she wants to  come back home and be accepted and she  wants what's his you're in my seat I  would love for someone else to rule but  it can't be you you're just the worst  some of the happiest times have been  beating people up I've really enjoyed us  I don't speak today I can just throw  axes into someone's Goz that's been good  you